und zwar geht es mir darum die kinder
und jugendlichen also ich glaube wir
haben durch corona alle irgendwo
verloren aber für mich sind gerade die
kinder und die jugendlichen sich die
ganz großen verlierer in der korona
pandemie und gar nicht aus
gesundheitlicher sicht sondern weil sie
unter den crooner maßnahmen unter den
beschränkungen gelitten haben vor allen
dingen natürlich unter den über wochen
monate geschlossenen schulen und
kindergärten
da gibt es viele lern rückstände die
kaum aufzuholen sind vor allen dingen
die ich für die kinder die es ohnehin
schwer hatten die aus familien kommen wo
die unterstützend nicht so da ist die
haben kaum eine chance haben aufzuholen
was da versäumt wurde es gibt psychische
und physische
einschränkungen eine studie der
uniklinik hamburg eppendorf hat
herausgefunden dass jedes dritte kind
unter psychischen einschränkungen
leiden
ja wirklich heftigen problem und ja das
ist aus meiner sicht falsch gemacht hat
haben die kinder und jugendlichen auch
keine lobby gehabt die kinder sind haben
zurückgesteckt aus solidarität mit den
erwachsenen und den älteren menschen die
sie schützen sollten und man hat sie
komplett vergessen und auch heute
vermisse ich immer noch das klare
bekenntnis der politik dass es nie
wieder zu schulschließungen kommen wird
das ist eine garantie gipfel
präsenzunterricht bald das ist das was
wir unbedingt brauchen um unseren
kindern und jugendlichen ihr recht auf
bildung wieder zurückzugeben also ich
hab mir auch drei kinder wie eine schule
gehen zwei sind geimpft als noch nicht
geben voller 11 ist und ich bin nicht
ihrer meinung weil ich möchte nicht dass
der sich mit bewohner infiziert auch
wenn er jetzt noch nicht geimpft ist und
die politik weiß nicht was mit dieser
pandemie noch passiert und wir müssen
auch mal sehen wir haben ja alle
geschrieben wie schrecklich spät die
große koalition mit dem impfen
angefangen hat dass sie das zuspiel
besorgt hatte war die eu kommission
diese kritik für uns war richtig aber
jetzt ist das für euch da und jetzt ist
es an uns jetzt muss die bevölkerung
sich impfen lassen und wer will dass die
schulen nicht wieder zu gehen der muss
sich impfen lassen das müssen wir als
bürger jetzt aufstellen und wer hierzu
guckt und in seiner whatsapp gruppe
gelesen hat dass das alles vielleicht
doch nicht so der soll sich noch mal
informieren und sollen sich impfen
lassen wer will dass die schulen auf
bleiben der kann nicht auf frau merkel
wie offen er muss auf impfen hoffen das
ist der weg aus der pandemie aber ich
kann auch nicht die kinder dafür bluten
lassen wenn erwachsene menschen
selbstbestimmt die entscheidung treffen
sich nicht impfen zu lassen schauen sie
mein land geben neukölln zur schule da
hatten wir zwischenzeitlich krasse
inzidenz und wenn dort eine gefahr einer
infektion besteht dann will ich
selbstverständlich dass man da nicht
hingeht ich möchte beides ich möchte
schulunterricht und sicherheit und da
komme ich nicht mit einem versprechen
von frau merkel da komme ich hin wenn
die bevölkerung sich solidarisch impfen
lassen
das glaub ich lese wir sehen ja dass die
verläufe bei kindern und da will ich
niemandem zu nahe treten aber doch
deutlich anders sind auch unsere kurve
ihr kind gerne nehmen aber ich möchte es
nicht nehmen nehmen das risiko für meine
kinder war das ja auch drei kinder da
sehen wir ja doch einen gewissen
unterschied und wir sind auch bei der
frage natürlich lassen sich die lehrer
helfen auch ein richtiger punkt aber
wenn man sich anschaut was passiert ist
als zum beispiel die fdp
kultusministerin nordrhein westfalen
nach den osterferien die schulen wieder
aufgemacht hat daher meine eindrücke
hatten die hatten mord begangen so wurde
sie attackiert umgekehrt hatten wir hier
in berlin eine bildungssenatorin die
doch wirklich der meinung war als alle
bundesländer schon die schulen geöffnet
hatten man könne hier schön die schulen
am liebsten bis zu den sommerferien noch
geschlossenheit und das wurde dann per
gerichtsbeschluss wurden hier mussten
hier in berlin die schulen wieder
geöffnet werden also ich habe den
eindruck der ein oder andere fotos oder
bildungsminister hat sich hier zum anti
bildungsminister entwickelt und fand es
offenbar total attraktiv zu sagen wir
lassen die kinder also es gibt keine
gruppe in der bevölkerung die so viel
getestet wird wie derzeit die kinder ich
würde da wirklich davor warnen der
pappkameraden aufzubauen es gibt kein
bildungsminister der die schulen gerne
schließt das sind da habe ich ehrlich
gesagt wirklich
anders in berlin ich
glaube nicht dass die berliner
kultusminister bildungsministerin die
schulen zu lassen wird der punkt ist
doch die kinder waren solidarisch mit
und somit den alten und jetzt müssen wir
solidarisch sein und unsere solidarität
mit hinein indem wir uns alle impfen und
das ist der punkt und jede andere
diskussion wir können uns unterhalten
fünf tage quarantäne keine quarantäne
für nichtbetroffene masken können wir
alles reden aber war das im zentrum der
debatte der ausweg ist es im verkehr
dann erzählen sie mir wenn alle
erwachsenen geimpft wird wie schütze ich
denn die grundschüler wir werden
natürlich auch irgendwann sagen ja
hoffentlich daran wird gearbeitet auch
eine impfung haben irgendwann für
jüngere kinder und natürlich müssen wir
gucken dass wir diese kinder möglichst
in sicherheit alexander was sagen sie
ich war kürzlich bei bayer palmer in
tübingen und da habe ich auch mit herr
palmer darüber diskutiert hat einmal
gesagt er würde seine kinder nicht
impfen lassen die eine ist jetzt elf
wird bei 12 die anderen so ein kleiner
und da der infarkt gesagt da würde ich
gerne in reaktion darauf ist er hat
nämlich gesagt das risiko der erkrankung
sieht er als geringer an für seine
kinder als wenn sie cola bekommen was
sagen sie es gibt ja auch studien zu
sich weiter nicht auf der schule boris
palmers kinder sind aber meine kinder
bewegen sich durch berlin berlin ist
eine unübersichtliche stadt berlin hat
auch gruppen die das mit dem impfen noch
nicht vollständig erreicht hat dass das
sinnvoll ist und es ist einfach so diese
ganze politische diskussion masken hier
und lockt da das sollen wir alles führen
das ist richtig und auch kontrovers aber
wir dürfen nicht die verunsicherung der
bevölkerung streuen der weg raus aus
krone ist impfen wenn wir eine impfquote
erreichen die 70 prozent das ist das
besser als 60 sie kostet ist noch besser
und das müssen wir jetzt bringen als
bevölkerung wir wollen jetzt mal an der
reihe ich habe mich hier kinder
eingestochen
der elf ist dass sich und er ist auch
nicht geben aber ich würde es gerne
natürlich haben fragen mich natürlich
auch obmann elfjährige theoretisch
könnte wird natürlich nicht geben für
das 11 12 geht aber ich finde auch nicht
die tatsache ist ja nicht eine sache des
kulturkreises zudem an zwischen
kulturkreis köthen mann gehört ob man
sich impfen lässt oder nicht sondern es
gibt auch unter den ja wie soll ich
sagen
einheimischen der einheitlichen
bevölkerung die das impfen aus
ideologischen gründen ablehnen das ist
schade und es ist wirklich fatal weil
die auch dazu beitragen was ihr recht
ist aber trotzdem tragen dazu bei dass
wir weiterhin mit masken und mit diesen
problemen hier uns zu beschäftigen haben
war es aber auch kein mensch hat hier
tatsächlich ein patentrezept denn wir
haben noch nicht mit dieser pandemie
gelebt wir wissen nicht was da kommt wir
wissen nicht ob sie nicht noch mal
mutiert wir wissen nicht ob das die
kinder in irgendeiner form anstieg also
wir leben hier wirklich in der lage und
da kann man sagen kinder klar hätten sie
haben sie das recht zur schule zu gehen
für eltern ist das eine riesenbelastung
zu hause zu sein das homeschooling
aber ich finde es genauso falsch zu
sagen inzidenz interessiert uns nicht
mehr wir haben zum teil 200 300 der
instanzen zum teil 500 der in sie denn
da kann mir doch keiner erzählen dass
das nicht auch bei der masse
auswirkungen hat auf das geschehen in
den krankenhäusern und sonstwo also das
heißt zu sagen das interessiert uns
nicht mehr was relevant war noch vor
drei vier monaten und wir orientieren
uns jetzt irgendwie nachgelagerter
krankenhaus belegung bettenbelegung kann
nicht das ziel sein was uns durch die
nächste phase und die wird kommen dieser
pandemie bringt ja noch nötig will sagen
dass sie nämlich das thema das sie als
letztes noch einmal ihren standpunkt
vertreten dürfen also wenn wir sagen wir
wissen nicht ganz genau was das kochen
mit den kindern was wir wissen ist dass
die schule schließen kitas diese massive
negative auswirkungen auf die kinder das
haben wir gesichert und deswegen werde
ich das nebeneinanderstellen wir sitzen
jetzt hier alle fünf leute ohne maske
wir halt mich anderthalb meter abstand
finden wir total okay wie kann man dann
ernsthaft sagen
nicht kennt ja die kinder werden auch
getestet ständig wie kann man denn sagen
das ist ok aber in schule wo es wirklich
um um lebenschancen gibt da ist das aber
nicht möglich dass es für mich so irre
sogar das darf man nicht machen
[Musik]